il recharge de la fiabilité
en gros
[Musique]
je recherche de la fiabilité bon bah
déjà donc Guillaume et Raymond éliminé
d'office bien entendu non mais c'est la
famille Gilles tu comprends bien sûr
mais carrément oui mais c'est la
sécurité
mais tout le monde c'est le physique et
l'argent attends attends
et l'humour et l'humour
faire vraiment confiance à la personne
que quand elle dit quelque chose elle le
fait qu'elle soit fiable oui je pense
que c'est très important est-ce que tu
te reconnais là-dedans
des fois on dit qu'on va faire et on
fait pas c'est pas qu'on n'est pas
fiable c'est qu'on a pas le temps une
journée c'est que 24 heures des fois on
viendra on oublie de Fener ça veut dire
que si t'es pas fiable ça veut dire que
tu mens parce que j'aime pas ce mot-là
la fièvre mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
parce que tu es en retard
tu viens pas hein
une femme vous êtes là à 9h à 9h vous
êtes là arrêtez pas d'autre rendez-vous
frérot arrête un peu
non mais c'est vrai ça va franchement
Gilles la fiabilité
il est même plus que fiable ah oui c'est
un peu trop la limite tu es content
de la tentation
la fiabilité non moi c'est une bagnole
on veut une bagnole fiable pas une femme
partenaire bravo
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors attention en numéro 4 on a
l'humour
sans des célibataires je recherche
quelqu'un de drôle voilà ouais ma
grand-mère elle disait si tu ne fais
rire la moitié dans ton lit femme qui
riment entier dans ton lit mais elle
m'avait pas dit comment il fallait ramer
pour l'autre
l'humour Béatrice très important rire
c'est la santé c'est Patrick Fiori
très important
l'humour donc ça va être le charisme
aussi c'est très important
pour l'instant on va voir qui se
rapproche le plus qui a les cinq après
hein Bernard Montiel pas mal fiabilité
humour vous les avez non j'ai pas du mot
et fiabilité non moi j'ai une
philosophie
nouveau quéquette en fait ah d'accord
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention
[Rires]
veulent des gens qui crient non
ça c'est important
si ta meuf non mais si ta meuf ou ton
mec aime je sais pas elle marcher tu
dois des sandales
de l'attention mais moi personnellement
je trouve que c'est pire d'avoir
quelqu'un qui vous ment plutôt quelqu'un
qui n'est pas attentionné le mensonge
pour moi c'est la fiabilité comme
Delphine c'est catastrophique c'est un
tue l'amour absolu
vous vous êtes très fiable pour les
rendez-vous tout ça un jour vous m'avez
donné rendez-vous à New York pour Noël
c'était là je dis Cyril je suis devant
Central Park est-ce que tu es là oui
répondu non frérot
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
même pas je vais arriver non frérot
alors attention c'est fait pour acheter
la fiabilité aussi bravo endormir la
personne alors
c'est intéressant parce que vous avez
dit si quelqu'un aime marcher vous allez
lui acheter des chaussures ou alors
qu'en fait il y en a d'autres qui vont
juste aller marcher avec la personne
ça va si j'ai une voiture c'est pourquoi
tant pour la regarder
c'est bon
en fait la tension
à prendre le crédit pour acheter la
et l'autre je marche et puis tu
marcheras à côté tu me fais pas chier
c'est vrai quoi
tu as raison en fait l'attention c'est
quoi le titre en anglais
non faut passer du temps avec la
personne il faut s'intéresser son son
énergie son attention
je me retiens de péter là ce que je suis
entre deux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et je me retiens je me retiens
de me détendre
[Applaudissements]
pardon pardon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vrai
oui légèrement vrai ouais
j'ai dit oui oui
un truc et qui est vrai et je le dis et
c'est important de le signaler soit pour
ceux qui nous regardent parce que
souvent les personnes qui ont des gars
sont décrié et moi je le dis souvent
et bravo Jean-Marie
à moitié pardonné
et d'ailleurs tu auras les jeunes mariés
pendant les six premiers mois le mec
fait attention même les gros péteurs
et on dit il va partir contre les
rideaux
et je vais pas me faire rigoler mais
après six mois après six mois c'est la
guerre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ici on
ritanrez pas sur France Inter
et heureusement d'ailleurs on est
tellement content
et moitié sortie
[Rires]
en deuxième position en deuxième
position parce que recherche est
célibataire il y a le respect
le respect 38 % des sons
alors on va tout dire le respect ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire quoi le respect
si si ça veut dire je te respecte tu me
respectes
tu vois des tatouages
aujourd'hui qu'on me respecte pas
je veux que tu m'insultes en allemand
je ne quéquette
le respect Delphine mais en fait je
pense que le respect c'est tellement
normal de l'avoir que ça devrait pas
être dans le classement exactement
les attentions qu'on a pour sa femme
c'est une forme de respect parce que
c'est la mettre sur un piédestal aussi
il a grandi
[Rires]
c'est le pigeon voyageur là
il fait comme ça
[Rires]
au début au début tu l'as sur les boules
et après tu as les médailles
la première chose que recherchez
célibataire là je vous dis on tourne
autour du pot c'est la sincérité l'eau
mais c'est quoi ce classement
[Musique]
vous à part la propreté vous avez tout
[Rires]
pas du tout mais voilà vous savez quoi
je crois que c'est une question de
génération ça ce sont des réactions de
jeunes tu as raison non non
c'est on est en idéalise
et puis Daniel elle te dit ce que je
veux que ce que ce qui vient à l'esprit
voilà la personne qui qui se présente
voilà non mais c'est ça
je pense qu'il faudrait rajouter la
communication et le sexe aussi
c'est une chanson tranquillement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et toi madame moi je dirais l'ambition
moi c'est très important que l'homme
avec qui je suis et une ambition
dévorante qu'il a envie de réussir qu'il
soit là c'est pas besoin qu'il ait de
l'argent à la base mais en tout cas
qu'il ait envie d'en avoir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu sais ce que les femmes ont 3 jours
par mois à peu près en moyenne qui ne
dure que trois jours par mois c'est le
salaire de leur mari
[Rires]
alors cette blague alors je me
désolidaris de cette blague
tout ton pognon ça lui prend tout le
mois forcément que tu as beaucoup
d'argent
que toi bah exactement bah oui oui c'est
sûr j'espère même bravo mon Bernard
heureusement que tu es là pour le
remettre sur leboncoin
alors il est il est 32 déjà
Bernard comment tu vas manger
une vitesse Géraldine alors moi je veux
qu'il soit très propre et très important
physique évidemment c'est très très
important parce que même s'il nous fait
rire si on est voilà on est pas tiré ça
n'a aucun sens et ensuite je dirais quoi
non il y a qu'est-ce qui manque
là-dedans dans cette liste
pour Géraldine tu as eu un
une histoire avec quelqu'un
propre non mais je pourrais pas
l'envisager en fait je trouve que c'est
très important quelqu'un propre
tout est vrai là dedans moi j'adore tout
est vrai
je te retrouve pas du tout
ce que cherche est célibataire en
attendant tout ça vous allez continuer à
chercher
[Applaudissements]
non mais sérieux vraiment et la même
chose qu'est-ce qui se passe en ce
moment il y a un mec qui fait
parfaitement l'amour à sa femme un mec
on a pas un seul Dieu au plus marre quoi
il suffit d'être sincère sincèrement
j'ai pas envie de baiser
c'est magique ça c'est génial Punta Cana
non on fait moins rire
imaginez quelqu'un de radinateur
on est d'accord